the Ukrainian troops here don't want us
to say you wear this is they don't want
to give away their location but we're
about 15 kilometers outside Mariupol
which is a modern European city and this
is the trench network that they have dug
to try to defend it this area has been
dug out it's pre-positioned for a tank
to drive into in that direction I won't
say exactly how far but is the position
that they believe is the rebel frontline
they have used earthmovers to take it
out it's all been done pretty quickly
some of the earth it's falling in as we
walk through them this is one of the
machine gun positions the men here who
have brought sleeping mats wilmut
calculus glory to Ukraine
they are preparing to defend themselves
from this position these are pretty
rudimentary defenses this is just loose
earth piled on top for many of the
people who are Manning them our
volunteer soldiers working with very
limited resources but from these
trenches they're preparing to fight an
enemy they say has superior weaponry and
technology and that they believe is
backed by Russia one of the world's
largest military powers